I have a great day we hope you enjoy our
new way of living
you can check out anytime you like but
you can never my girlfriend Lily and I
had tried to make it work in New York
but we couldn't find jobs so we moved in
with my grandparents in New Jersey they
say some people have an adjustment
period when they move here
I guess Lily is still adjusting they
want to be where it's happening I
understand you see you've got a
grandmother who's still so cool I heard
they have orgies wife-swapping swinger
parties out in those retirement homes I
mean it gets crazy it's not a retirement
home
no it's an active adult community what
do you really want to do about them what
do you mean do you think about how
anxious you are because that's like
literally all I think about how anxious
I am to do something where's my
grandfather well I mean you're
overreacting I think can you just can
you just come here tonight please why
don't you come here I have to go find
him I can't just walk away so what's it
like what's it like getting home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you